Robert Muller offers Tony Podesta a very
special deal president Trump prepares
for a second prudent meeting and we
checked the mailbag I'm Ben Shapiro this
is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]
what a week folks got to tell you what
went on this week and there's a lot more
to come on today's show but first I want
to remind you that the job that you
currently hold in ten years you're not
going to be holding it in five years if
the studies show what they show then you
probably won't be holding it either
which means that you need to be
constantly revising and updating your
resume Skillshare is the place that
allows you to do this by adding new
skills every single day to your skillset
Skillshare is an online learning
platform with over 20,000 classes in
business design technology and more you
can take classes and everything from
social media marketing and illustration
to data science and mobile photography
you name it they've got it in all their
classes are like 45 minutes long taught
by experts whether you're trying to
deepen your professional skill set or
start a side hustle or just explore that
new passion skill share is there to keep
you learning it and thriving I've taken
classes from them in both social media
marketing and watercolours I'm diverse
that way go check it out it's really
awesome join the millions of students
already learning on Skillshare today
with a special offer just for my
listeners get two months of Skillshare
for just 99 cents right now Skillshare
is offering ben shapiro shell listeners
two months of unlimited access to over
20,000 classes for just 99 cents to sign
up go to Skillshare comm slash Shapiro
that skill shared comm slash reparo to
start your two months right now again
Skillshare comm slash appear I'll use
that slash appear oh let them know that
we sent you okay I want to talk today a
little bit about a story that no one is
talking about and it really is a
disturbing story because it suggests
where the right in the country is headed
I don't mean the trumpian right the evil
right I'm talking about the pansy right
I'm talking about their folks on the
right who will run from any controversy
because they are deeply afraid of being
miscast as a racist sexist bigoted
homophobe and someone who's frequently
miscast this way I got to tell you the
only way to stand up to the social
justice mob is to simply stand up to
them and say I'm not those things that
you're full of crap it's the only way to
do it but with that said there's a story
that really went unnoticed this week
that is pretty disturbing to me here is
the story it's from Oregon live it says
this US Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell on Thursday suddenly announced
the withdrawal of Oregon federal
prosecutor Ryan bounds his controversial
nomination for a vacancy on the ninth US
Circuit Court of Appeals the 9th Circuit
Court of Appeals is the most liberal
Circuit Court of Appeals in the country
and this replacement was for a pretty
conservative judge on the 9th Circuit
Court of Appeals the move came about 45
minutes after a Senate vote had been
scheduled to confirm bounds McConnell
offered no explanation
but Oregon's senators later said it
became apparent Republicans didn't have
the vote so what did this judge do that
prevented his nomination to the 9th
Circuit Court of Appeals he's 44 years
old and he had an opportunity to be
sitting on this court for a very very
long time so what did he do that was
just so terrible that Republicans could
not support him
well according to Oregon live he hadn't
disclosed inflammatory college writings
about sexual assault the rights of
workers people of color and the LGBTQ
community to the Oregon committee when
questioned about his thoughts on
diversity or if there was anything
embarrassing from his past perhaps
because he's 44 and he wrote this crap
when he was 18 or 19 and the second
we're gonna go through those writings
and we'll try to determine what if
anything that he said is so offensive
that literally 25 years later he should
not be allowed to sit on one of the
nation's courts both Ron Wyden and Jeff
Merkley of Oregon repeatedly warned the
Republican colleagues that a
confirmation of bounds would signal an
end to bipartisan cooperation in
judicial nominations pending one hundred
and one year custom okay first of all
there is no bipartisan cooperation in
judicial nominations Republicans have
simply been voting by straight majority
to confirm all of these nominees
it was Harry Reid who ended the policy
of judicial confirmations as a
bipartisan exercise during the Bush
years and then it was Harry Reid who
again decided it would be a wise and
brilliant idea to end the filibuster for
judicial nominees so there hasn't that
this idea there's been judicial
nomination confirmation bipartisanship
is just nonsense it hasn't been true for
a very long time Wyden said I'm
gratified that the Senate has come to
its senses and that longtime proven
practices of bipartisanship for judicial
nominations have prevailed over partisan
efforts to force through a deeply flawed
and compromised nominee Wyden said I
think there's going to affect other
nominees and strengthen the whole advice
and consent rule for members of the US
Senate it's going to be good for the
nominees being truthful I think it's a
win for the Oregon way he says it wasn't
a complete surprise because several
Republicans were looking carefully at
this but on the other hand we knew a lot
of pressure we brought to bear this was
a nominee from the Fed Society the
Federalist Society which has
extraordinarily huge leverage in driving
through nominees so according to my
sources in the Judiciary Committee as
well as Senator Tim's as well as this
this open report from Oregon Live
senator Tim Scott of South Carolina
who's normally a really good senator the
Republican caucuses lone black senator
appears to have been a pivotal no vote
in a statement Scott said he couldn't
support bounds of his name went to a
vote Thursday after meeting with him he
said after talking with the nominee
last night and meeting with him today I
had unanswered questions that led to me
being unable to support him so does
Scott actually believe that this nominee
was a racist does this mean that he was
a racist so according to the reports
Merkley said he had heard that bounds
would be defeated by about 70 votes
including the 49 Democratic senators of
his nomination been put to a vote why
exactly was he was he shut off now let's
look at the text of what he said all the
way back when he was hit when he was at
Stanford University in 1995 when he was
19 years old so here are some of the
excerpts that were cited by the Alliance
for justice which is a far left group
attempting to get this guy to prevent
him from sitting on a court again he's
written 25 years ago and this is the
stuff that prevented a guy from sitting
on a federal court because Republicans
were too pansy to actually just confirm
the guy so here's what he wrote during
my years in our multicultural Garden of
Eden again this is 1995 at Stanford I
have often marveled at the odd
strategies that some of the more
strident racial factions of the student
body employ in their attempts to
heightened consciousness build tolerance
promote diversity and otherwise convince
us to partake of that fruit which
promises to open our eyes to a PC
version of the knowledge of good and
evil I'm mystified because these tactics
seem always to contribute more to
restricting consciousness aggravating
intolerance and pigeonholing cultural
identities than many a Nazi book-burning
that's bad I'm confused that's true okay
that part's actually true
multiculturalism on campus is a way for
people to pigeonhole each other into
various racial categories and then to
shut down free thought so that's not
wrong even if you think it's mildly
overstated that is you're gonna keep
them off a court for that how about this
one I submit that the multicultural
lease does when they divide up by race
for their feel-good ethnic hoedowns
engage in nearly all of the fundamental
behaviors of groupthink because they do
okay I've been on college campuses this
is what happens it is group thing okay
if a black person is an individualist
and a thoroughgoing capitalist to his
shoes victimhood status and it's
concomitant entitlements race thinkers
are quick to brand him and bounds them
listed out to rocket Ori terms that are
often used including sellout again I'm
confused
this is why Republicans wouldn't vote
for this guy for the Ninth Circuit Court
of Appeals because he said two things
about multiculturalism
he said the existence of ethnic
organizations is no inevitable
prerequisite to maintaining a diverse
community white students after all seem
to be doing all right without an area in
Student Union okay
he's making the case against an Aryan
Student Union that's not a case in favor
of an Aryan Student Union
he's saying that when you divide people
up by ethnicity what you are actually
doing on college campuses is preventing
everybody from seeing each other as
equals and as Americans again true okay
so none of those things should rule this
guy off the court what else well he said
there's nothing really inherently wrong
with University failing to punish an
alleged rapist regardless his guilt in
the absence of adequate certainty
there's nothing the university can do to
objectively ensure that the rapist does
not strike again so the case that he was
making in this particular argument is
not in favor of rapists he was saying
that the university is not responsible
for jailing people the police are
responsible for jailing people and then
if somebody alleges rape on a college
campus we shouldn't have these sort of
campus witch hunts where people are
immediately deemed guilty and then
tossed out of school this has become a
serious problem on America's college
campuses so again he's not completely
wrong here
he says expelling students is probably
not going to contribute a great deal to
RIT victims recovery there's no more
imperative to risk egregious error in
doing so again the case that he's making
here is the same he is essentially
saying that throwing people off of
campus in the absence of an actual court
trial that would land them in jail is
going to be a serious problem you're
going to have kangaroo courts
determining whether people are guilty or
not based on lack of evidence and you
have had this happen right mattress girl
over at NYU or Columbia rather this is
still a thing where people allege things
that are not true remember at Columbia
University there's a woman I can't
remember her name Emma sulking what's I
think it was she call herself mattress
girl because she'd go around campus
carrying a mattress alleging that she
had been raped by a foreign student and
it turns out that he had text that
proved that she was not actually raped
she is still upheld by the left as a
sign of the campus rape epidemic that's
happening on campuses and this guy sued
the university cos Columbia punished him
he sued the University and he won a
couple million dollar settlement from
the University this sort of stuff does
happen on campuses so this is this is
the writing that this guy got thrown off
a court for that Republicans said they
wouldn't vote for him for and bounds
even gave them the stalinist apology
right he even gave them an email that is
the the judicial nominee even gave them
an email apologizing for all the stuff
he said achieving a more egalitarian and
inclusive society has always been
centrally important to me appropriate
sensitivities the views of others
particularly those from marginalized
communities about how best to pursue
that aim however came to me only after
I'd left college for the workaday world
I regret that and I apologize to you all
for the obnoxious
just tone and misguided sentiments
you'll hear about because of it please
know that my commitment to our shared
mission will only be redoubled by this
unpleasant reminder of my errors of
nearly a quarter century ago okay that's
just I'm sorry it's a bunch of crap it's
a bunch of crap like the stuff that you
wrote in college when that bad even if
you think it was that bad it was back in
college and unless you have anything to
show me from the last 25 years
demonstrating the guy's a secret member
of the KKK I'm gonna go you're in this
is idiotic this is idiotic it's idiotic
people do change from the time they're
17 years old I should know I was reading
a syndicated column when I was 17 years
old do I stand by everything I ever
wrote when I was 17 no because I'd be an
idiot if I did if you've changed no
opinions you ever held since you were 17
years old it's because you haven't been
doing any thinking so there's that
element of this we have to oh man let's
go through his college writings and
determine whether he's secretly a
segregationist and then it turns out the
stuff this guy wrote wasn't even that
bad the stuff this guy wrote is largely
true and he's kicked off a court for
that now what's hilarious about this is
the left does not have the same sense of
composure the left does not have the
same sense that we have to be above the
fray when it comes to these political
battles the left is not cowardly this
way they're leftist who members of
Occupy during college who will sit on
our nation's federal courts they the
left the left worships at the altar of
people who are actual legitimate
terrorists well people like Assata
Shakur they're their actual people who
are alleged terrorists that the left
tries to tries to uphold Maya abu-jamal
who shot a cop and we are told that the
left is going to hero eyes those people
William Ayers is a professor at a major
university after being a legitimate
domestic terrorist during the 1970s and
so as his wife Bernardine Dohrn yeah all
of this stuff according to the left is
totally fine it's totally fine the left
is never shy about this stuff I promise
you all the people who are writing
extreme stuff today in their student
newspapers about how Donald Trump is the
worst person in the world all those
people will be sitting on federal courts
in 30 years mark my words and no one on
the left will care it is only the right
that is so shy about its own viewpoint
with regard to multiculturalism that
they run away when something is mild as
these writings from a prospective judge
come up it's really absurd
it's truly absurd I'm talking a little
bit more about that in just a second
first let's talk about that wheat coffee
you've been drinking you ever found
yourself wincing at the weak taste of
the coffee from one of these
left-leaning corporate brands you
probably thought
listen I wish they spent less time on
meaningless biased training and bathroom
policy reform letting homeless people
pee in their toilets well this is why
you need black rifle coffee founded by
former Special Operations vets black
rifle delivers the best roasts to order
coffee right to your door this
guarantees you are getting fresh premium
coffee with every order in addition to
great coffee and gear black rifle coffee
company as a coffee club that makes
things easy no lines no running out just
great coffee shipped right to your door
every month hassle free plus when you
join their coffee club you'll receive
discounts and offers not available to
other customers not only does black
rifle coffee company make one hell of a
cup of coffee they also give a portion
of their sales to vets and first
responder causes when you choose black
rifle you're choosing a company that
supports our veterans and serves coffee
and culture to those who love America
visit black rifle coffee comm slash Ben
and receive 15% off your order that's
black rifle coffee calm / ban for 15%
off black rifle coffee calm / Ben go
check it out awesome guys they do
awesome work black rifle coffee calm /
ban okay so back to this judge this
prospective judge bounds who's shut down
by representing her Tim Scott who
couldn't apparently say that he thought
that this guy was a racist he just felt
uncomfortable with him hey just cuz you
feel uncomfortable with somebody doesn't
mean that person shouldn't sit on a
federal court it depends on how
sensitive you are right I believe that
there are levels of discomfort that
passed beyond discomfort into outright
antagonism and sometimes that's
justified but if you're just
uncomfortable with the way somebody
phrase something back in college even
though you agree with the underlying
message maybe you ought to think about
the stuff that you wrote back in college
and thought back in college and think
wow do I agree with the way I phrased
everything way back when
okay bounds apologize before the
Judiciary Committee for his often
high-handed an overheated tone of his
Stanford commentary about campus
politics he says the intentions behind
those articles were always to see
greater tolerance and mutual
understanding on campus that was always
my aim the Judiciary Committee voted 11
to 10 in June along party lines to
forward bounces nominations to the
Senate floor
Democrats blasted their Republican
colleagues and president Trump's
administration for trying to pack courts
with extremists judges Ron Wyden who's a
socialist idiot accused bounds
misrepresenting and covering up
disturbing intolerant writings from his
past is not a cover-up and they're not
disturbing in they're not intolerant he
says what really outraged and shocked me
was his comparison of organizations that
promote multiculturalism tolerance here
in America to Nazi rallies
so that was that quote that I read you a
little bit earlier where he said that a
lot of these ethnic groups do more to
shut off thought than a Nazi
book-burning would honestly that's not
completely wrong
having been on campus having spent an
enormous amount of time on campus I've
been protested by exactly these groups
who have stood outside theaters where
I'm speaking shouting speech is violence
and attempting to shut down the speech
and prevent people from entering hey I
was at Cal State Los Angeles when many
of these student groups were calling out
their friends to block people from
entering the room hey that is a shutdown
of free speech by these exact campus
groups and we're supposed to believe
it's just terrible this guy wrote this
in at Stanford in 1995 it's just it's
absurd so I don't blame Democrats for
doing this they don't want a
conservative sitting on the court
shocker they don't want somebody who is
going to interpret the Constitution
according to its original meaning
sitting on the court shocker
what I am embarrassed by really
embarrassed by is the Republicans
including senators that I like I liked
him Scott I'm embarrassed by senators in
the Republican Party who will not stand
by a prospective judicial nominee
because they are quote unquote
embarrassed by some of the things that
that person said back when they were 19
years old at Stanford University things
that are objectively non embarrassing it
demonstrates the level to which all of
these these Republicans have been
bullied and cowed it demonstrates how
fast they run for the hills and here's
the thing they think there's gonna buy
them some sort of love from the left
they think that the left is going to
somehow treat them nicely don't work
that way John McCain was treated really
nicely by the left up until the point
where he ran for president in 2008 he
became a racist sexist bigoted homophobe
Mitt Romney was supposed to be a favor
to the left up until the point when you
ran against Barack Obama and which came
he became at which point he became a guy
who wanted to put black people back and
chain strap dogs to the top of his car
and hated women
hey all you people in the Republican
Party including you senator Scott if you
think you're gonna get off easy with the
left by shutting down the nomination of
people like this guy balance you are out
of your mind they will come after you
just as hard and twice as badly because
they know that you can be cowed this
stuff is sort of stuff has got to stop
on the part of Republicans it really has
to end it's it's just egregious okay
meanwhile there's a lot of fallout now
from the Trump Putin meeting earlier
this week and there's some disturbing
stuff coming out of the Muller
investigation and I don't mean
disturbing about President Trump I mean
disturbing in the way that the Moller
investigation is approaching president
Trump and
members of frumps campaign so this is a
report from the Daily Caller it was
reported also at the on Tucker Carlson's
show last night basically the report is
that Tony Podesta who is obviously a top
honcho in the Democratic Party along
with his brother John Podesta
who they founded the Podesta group
together and then John Podesta was
Hillary Clinton's campaign chair well it
turns out that Tony Podesta has now been
flipped against Paul Manafort with a
promise of immunity here is Tucker
Carlson reporting on it last night
well tonight we can report exclusively
based on two separate sources we spoke
to today the Tony Podesta has been
offered immunity by robert muller to
testify against Paul Manafort in other
words for a near identical crime bill
and Hillary's friend could skate and
emerge completely unscathed
while Paul Manafort may rot in jail only
one of them made the mistake of chairing
Donald Trump's presidential campaign
okay and it's hard not to read it the
way the Tucker is reading it here now
the counter-argument would be this just
to be fair the counter-argument is that
Tony Podesta blew the Foreign Relations
Act the foreign actors Relations Act
it's called fara I'm trying remember
what it actually stands for it's the the
basic idea is that he didn't register as
a foreign agent and then he registered
late as a foreign agent which is another
thing that Paul Manafort did so they had
the same crime there it is fair to say
however that Paul Manafort is also being
charged for tax evasion in a way that
Tony Podesta is not so maybe you say
okay well we flip the lesser crime for
the greater crime the reason that they
are giving Podesta immunity is because
if they don't give him immunity he can
plead the fifth is the way that it works
legally is that you cannot plead the
fifth just because you feel like
pleading the fifth so let's say that you
are called as a witness in a criminal
trial but there is no actual chance that
you are going to be prosecuted and you
plead the fifth the judge will force you
to testify he'll say there's no
self-incrimination issue here because
you're not prosecuted if you offer Tony
Podesta immunity now he can't plead the
fifth okay so there try and get him to
testify against manna four-to-one Reid
is this is Muller attempting to roll up
all the members of the Trump campaign by
flipping a bunch of Democrats like Tony
Podesta by giving them immunity if
that's the case then Moeller is
politically biased and this is a bad
it's a bad look it's just a bad look the
other way to read this is the Tony
Podesta didn't commit the same crimes as
Paul Manafort and so him flipping home
flipping Podesta against manna Ford is
really just normal criminal
procedure I don't know the answer to
that all I can tell you is that it
doesn't look it doesn't look great
potestas lawyers have responded by by
hitting Carlson with a cease and desist
order because Carlson had previously
reported details of Podesta's
involvement in the Muller probe he
reported in October that Podesta was in
the special counsels crosshair Podesta's
lawyers had hit Carlson with a cease and
desist and the Daily Caller found
co-founder ignored all of that so it's
it's not good news for the Muller probe
that they had to do that and again it's
it's sort of lending credence to the
idea that Trump is putting out there
that the Muller probe is a get Trump
probe as opposed to something that is
objectively trying to go about the
prosecution of criminals in the United
States now with that said I in smooth
lending more I think credence to to some
of trumps complaints there's this
article in Reuters that is really sort
of disturbing this is an article from
Tim Weiner over at Reuters and here's
what he says says the foundations of
American national security are under
assault the battle lines are drawn on
one side stand the Federal Bureau of
Investigation the Central Intelligence
Agency the national security national
security agency on the other the
commander-in-chief of the United States
Donald Trump's appalling performance in
Helsinki was a subversive act he
rejected the conclusion of American
intelligence that his election was aided
by a Hydra headed active political
warfare controlled by the Kremlin he did
so with a wink and a smile for the
smirking autocrat who led the attack and
then this Reuters columnist continues by
ripping into Trump and then he says
about the intelligence community they
have the power to strike back for two
years now high ranking veterans of
American intelligence have sounded the
alarm about Trump in the starkest
language possible and then he quotes a
bunch of members of the Intel community
who have been warning about Trump
intelligence officers already have
provided reams of information to Muller
under the ambit of the law in little
more than a year mullah has brought to
court overwhelming evidence that Russian
military intelligence carried out the
covert operation while Trump
emphatically denies collusion signs
suggest that Muller can and will show
that the Russians were aided and abetted
by Americans Milan has one guilty pleas
in cooperation in the coming months a
noose around Trump whose lawyers keep
setting new conditions for an interview
at the president will likely tighten as
the special counsel closes in on 1600
Pennsylvania Avenue these cases never
could have been made without the FBI the
CIA and the NSA if the House of
Representatives slips from Republican to
Democrat November impeachment hearings
mail
in January again American intelligence
officials will provide the information
fueling these investigations now just a
second on to talk about why this sort of
angle is really really wrong headed and
really really dangerous and this
columnist for Reuters isn't the only one
who's taking this particular attack but
first I'm gonna talk about your air
filters I know exciting stuff but here's
the reality you are you are probably
breathing air that is not as clean as it
should be right now and you're probably
spending too much on your electric bills
according to the Department of Energy
the most expensive utility for most
Americans is that electric bill making
up roughly 9% of their annual housing
expenditure that number is aggravated
depending on where you live so in
California we get absolutely destroyed
in in there I mean I just I spend a
fortune every month on my energy bills
but one of the ways that you can prevent
this is by having air filters that
actually work and adding insult to
injury this allergy season is one of the
worst well you can help lower the bill
and make sure that your air system is
making your air clean by going over to
my friends and filter by and getting a
new set of filters America's leading
provider of HVAC filters for homes and
small businesses its filter by they
carry over 600 sizes if you're one of
those difficult people they can even
make them custom for you plus they ship
free within 24 hours and they're
manufactured right here in the United
States so there is no excuse and the
easiest thing by the way to set up
auto-delivery
it makes your life easier and you save
5% additionally extend the life of your
system it's getting hotter outside the
last thing you need is a busted HVAC
system on top of the allergies so go
check it out save money breathe better
with filter by dot-com exciting stuff
filter by comm tell them I sent you
because you need a new filter just get
it done and you don't have to worry
about it anymore
filter by dot-com go check it out right
now okay so the it is not just this
Reuters columnist who's praising the
deep state today on the same day that
Muller apparently is using Tony Podesta
to go after Paul Manafort in what looks
like a non a non decent arrangement it's
Eugene Robinson his lefty columnist -
over at The Washington Post he has a
column today called god bless the deep
state and his main contention his main
objection is he suggests that the
administration is so dangerous that we
need all of these bureaucrats in place
to stop the administration from dib from
being dangerous he says before this
hairbrained and reckless administration
is history the nation will have cause to
celebrate the public servants derided by
trumpets as the supposed deep state the
term itself is
Buganda intended to cast a sinister
light upon men and women whom Trump and
his minions find annoyingly
knowledgeable and experienced there are
not participants in any kind of dark
conspiracy rather they are feared and
loathed by the President and is wrecking
crew of know-nothings because they have
spent years often decades mastering the
details of foreign and domestic policy
god bless them with the supine
congressman willing to play the role it
is assigned by the Constitution the deep
state stands between us and the abyss
and then he talks all about how the deep
state is basically leaking to the media
all this information and talking to
Robert Muller and building a case
against the President of the United
States
he says Democrats in Congress are
powerless the Republican leadership
spineless experienced government
officials know that their job is to
serve the president but what if the
president does not serve the best
interests of the nation in this
emergency the loyal and honorable deep
State has a higher duty it's called
patriotism to understand how dangerous
that says so basically you have the
President of the United States who
accuses the intelligence services of
being politicized and the response of
the left is good I'm glad they're
politicized because the president is
just that dangerous now imagine if the
situation reversed Barack Obama were
pursuing his awful awful Iran deal and
people inside the so-called deep state
were leaking all sorts of information
about the Iran deal and making a
criminal case that the members of the
Obama administration were lying to the
American public for example do you think
the left would be quite so saying when
about the deep state or they say listen
Obama was elected to do a job if
Congress wants to check in Congress can
check him that's the way our government
works unelected bureaucrats do not get
to play their own role out here I think
that would have been the better case and
the stronger case and the more
intelligent case you cannot have an
executive agency that is not subject to
the purview of the president because
then you do have a rogue agency that is
subject to no one Congress can't curb
them the president can't curb them do
you really want a state in which those
with the greatest power over
surveillance and intelligence also have
the most power over our politics is that
really what you want put aside the
president for a second put aside how
much Lefty's put aside how much I hate
president Trump for just a second so you
really want the most powerful agencies
of the country the NSA the CIA and the
FBI have so much power that it's their
job now to curb and topple the President
of the United States those are the
people who also have power over your
emails and your call data those are the
people who you suddenly trust the same
leftist who five seconds ago we're
ripping into the Patriot Act suggesting
it was unpatriotic those
left us today are deeply excited about
these members of the so-called deep
state checking president Trump's
excesses if you don't like President
Trump there's a very very easy thing you
can do about it vote out Republicans in
November if you think that he's so
dangerous then get out there and give
money to your local Democratic candidate
but if you think the solution to this is
a bunch of bureaucrats appointed at the
highest levels and left in power for
years on end without any sort of serious
oversight I don't know what kind of
country you want to build it does
suggest the anti-democratic tendencies
as some folks on the Left that they hate
Trump so much they are willing to go
along with the so-called deep state
pretty amazing the same people who
should have learned their lesson after J
Edgar Hoover and Martin Luther King
suddenly they believe that the deep
state are people who are worthy of our
of our insane insane protection now do I
really think the people in the FBI CIA
and I say these are all bad people of
course not I've been very strongly
defending all of these people from what
I think is the unfair assault of
President Trump on their capabilities
with regards to the Russian
investigation but two things can be true
at once I can like that the FBI CIA and
NSA are doing their job investigating
Russian election interference and I can
also be wary of unelected bureaucrats in
any branch of the federal government
overriding their their constitutional
boundaries and impinging into normal
everyday electoral politics I don't want
the FBI interfering in the election any
more than I want the Russians
interfering in the election the Russians
are a foreign power the FBI is an
unelected bureaucracy they should not be
interfering in the election outside of
their normal processes of criminal
adjudication once you start turning this
into a political branch why should I
possibly trust that I can trust these
people with additional power why would I
possibly trust that these are people are
looking out for me and not looking out
for their own political interests
remember these are government agencies
government agencies have a couple of
different interests maximizing power and
maximizing their own money that means
that these are folks who are going to
manipulate the system or at least they
have an interest in manipulating the
system into giving us more surveillance
power and funding us better at the very
least that's a problem and that's why we
have democratic elected officials small
d-- democratic elected officials who are
going to provide a check against this
sort of apparatus but cheering on the
apparatus is mistaken by the way it
lends all sorts of credibility to trump
when he rips into the apparatus when he
says there is a deep state it's hard for
you to claim there's not
deep state while you're cheering for the
deep state if from says the deep states
out to get me and you say there is no
deep state but also I'm glad that didn't
even state is out to get you you got to
pick one of those things the excitement
to get President Trump has led people to
lose their basic notion their lose their
basic idea of how government ought to
work okay meanwhile in breaking news
that is not great for President Trump
the New York Times is now reporting that
Michael Cohen has secret tapes of
President Trump so perhaps this is the
reason why the the Muller investigation
was essentially trying to raid the Cohen
offices we still don't know why that
happened by the way you remember that
Michael Cohen president Trump's personal
lawyer his office was raided by the FBI
and there are questions as to what
exactly was the criminal activity at
issue and the suggestion was the
violated campaign finance law by paying
off stormy Daniels or somesuch it's
still very unclear to me that it's
legitimate that the FBI raided Michael
Cohen's office we're gonna have to see
what the prosecution looks like but the
New York Times reporting today that
President Trump's a longtime lawyer
Michael Kohn secretly recorded a
conversation with mr. Trump two months
before the presidential election in
which they discuss payments to a former
Playboy model who said she had an affair
with mr. Trump according to lawyers
another familiar is familiar with the
recording the FBI seized the recording
this year during a raid on mr. Cohen's
office the Justice Department is
investigating mr. Cohen's involvement in
paying women to tamp down embarrassing
news stories about mr. Trump ahead of
the 2016 election prosecutors want to
know whether that violated federal
campaign finance laws any conversation
with mr. Trump about those payments
would be of keen interest to them so I
guess that they're going to now claim
that because Trump actually had a clear
conversation with Michael Kohn about the
election and then about stormy Daniels
that Cohen paying off stormy Z annuals
and getting reimbursed by Trump was
actually a form of campaign finance
violation now again this comes from the
deep State House the New York Times find
out about this how does this fun well
according to lawyers and others familiar
with the recordings that's very deep
background right there's the way that it
works in journalism by the way just so
folks know is that when you talk with a
reporter you can use a couple of
different designations there's
off-the-record which means that the
reporter cannot report it but can use
the information that you are giving them
and to go look for other leads and then
there is on background which is to say
you can quote me but not by name there's
deep background which is to say you can
you can use the information that I'm
without attributing it to me and then
there is the and then there's on the
record which means that you can just
quote me
so these are people who are speaking on
deep background which means they're
probably pretty close to the
investigation and probably these actual
members of the Justice Department
talking to the New York Times and all
these people are trying to get Trump I
mean again the fact that all the stuff
leaks on a consistent basis is not good
for either the intelligence apparatus or
the Department of Justice or for
President Trump the recordings existence
furthers roz mr. Trump into questions
about tactics he and his associates used
to keep aspects of his personal and
business life a secret it highlights the
potential legal and political danger mr.
Cohen represents to mr. Trump once the
keeper of many of mr. Trump's secrets
mr. Cohen is now seen increasingly as
willing to cooperate with prosecutors
Giuliani Rudy Giuliani his Trump's
lawyer on this stuff now he says the
recording is less than two minutes and
demonstrates the president did nothing
wrong
noting that conversation suggests had
any knowledge of the payment in advance
he says in the big scheme of things it's
powerful exculpatory evidence we'll have
to see what exactly is on the tape again
these leaks are devastatingly bad for
the Department of Justice it's really
not good for trust in the system for
sure so yeah again all of this is to
suggest that when President Trump
complains about the deep state he's not
completely completely off-base okay in
just a second I want to talk about the
insanity that's happening on the view
with Jeanine Pirro I also want to talk a
little bit about Trump's relationship a
little bit more about Trump's
relationship with his own intelligence
community first you're gonna have to go
over to daily wire comm so you go over
to daily wire comm when you do you get
the rest of this show live you get the
rest of the under clayvin show live the
rest of Michael Noel's show live you get
to be part of our mailbag asked me alive
questions today subscribe right now and
you can ask me questions live I will
answer them for you and make your life
in estimable better so go check that out
for 99 dollars a year you got this the
leftist here is hot or cold tumblr go
check it out
it's a great deal also make sure that
you subscribe at YouTube and iTunes make
sure you hit the little bell on YouTube
so that you're notified every time we
bring out a new video of great Sunday
special episode that is coming out to
Sunday with Eric Weinstein you'll love
it
really intelligent guy man on the Left a
liberal who disagrees with me about many
issues agrees in the about some I love
those conversations because unlike
others I'm not intolerant to people
across the aisle when it comes to having
political conversation but go check that
out also we are the largest fastest
growing conservative podcast in the
nation
[Music]
so as I've been saying I'm deeply
skeptical of the intelligence community
leaking about Trump or the Democrats who
say that the intelligence community
going after Trump is a good thing for
the country I think the Department of
Justice leaking stuff to the New York
Times is deeply troubling obviously and
I suspect that that leak about Michael
Cohen is coming from the Department of
Justice with that said the President of
the United States should treat his
actual intelligence community well when
they are doing their jobs and one of the
big problems here is that he leaves them
out of the loop on a fairly regular
basis so the most obvious example of
this is yesterday Director of National
Intelligence dan coates who's basically
thrown under the bus by President Trump
this week he was appearing at some event
with Andrea Mitchell of NBC News and he
is told that Donald Trump plans a second
meeting with Vladimir Putin now I'm not
sure why we would have a second meeting
with Putin when the first meeting
obviously was such a mess but I guess
Trump wants to do that as sort of a
doubling down anyway dan coates is told
about this on stage his reaction says
something about Trump's relationship
with his own intelligence community at
this point I do want to say we have some
breaking news the White House has
announced on Twitter that Vladimir Putin
is coming to the White House in the fall
say that again
you vitamin yeah yeah okay so clearly
hey he's been blindsided by it by the
fact the president wants now Putin to
come to the White House yeah the
president look the president is a man of
many passions and and he does things on
the spur of the moment and at whim and
his coms office tends to repeat those
things on the spur of the moment and at
whim all I can say is it would be better
for the Trump administration if they
would coordinate these things a little
bit in advance you don't have
embarrassing moments quite like this
okay meanwhile the left demonstrates
that they do in fact have complete Trump
derangement syndrome so Jeanine Pirro
when Fox News was on the view how is
Jeanine Pirro gets me on the view and I
don't got to be on the view what is the
deal here guys okay what is this I've
been begging you to book me on the view
for literally years at this point now I
understand you don't want to have me on
the view I get you don't want to have me
on the view because it's gonna get weird
and ugly but that's the whole point
don't you want to be good TV so anyway
they have Jeanine Pirro on and it does
get weird and ugly
so Jeanine Pirro says to Whoopi Goldberg
that she has Trump derangement syndrome
which is clearly true and things get
wild did you just point at me listen I
don't have trumpet arrangement let me
tell you what I have okay the JIT gets
crazier from there Whoopi eventually
goes so nuts that she essentially throws
Jeanine Pirro off the set because
Jeanine Pirro says that Whoopi Goldberg
has Trump derangement syndrome which she
clearly does here's here's Whoopi
Goldberg losing her mind saying I'm done
and then and then bringing this nutty
segment to a crashing halt
to be a Latino
[Applause]
okay and so it ends like that but then
it gets even worse so Jeanine Pirro was
on Sean Hannity's radio show the other
day and Jeanine Pirro explains what
happened directly after that little tiff
when I went off the stage Sean
downstairs and I said something like
Whoopie I fought for victims my whole
life and she came at me as I was leaving
and she said eff you in my face
literally spitting at me if you get the
eff out of this building okay so
obviously she does not have from
derangement syndrome Whoopi Goldberg
obviously she's completely sane person
having normal political discourse this
is the level to which things have sunk
okay the level to which they I think
Whoopi Goldberg is representative of a
hardcore base of leftists that this is
how they feel that anyone who disagrees
with them is an evil evil human being
and you can't even have a discussion
about the issues now look Jeanine Pirro
is a very pro Trump guest there's no
question but they knew that when they
booked her if you're going to have
Jeanine Pirro on you at least have to
let her talk right this idea that you
bring on a guest and you don't let them
talk is so beyond absurd to me I don't
understand it at all when we do our
Sunday specials here on the venture Piro
show one of the things that I do is I
bring in people who disagree I brought
in sam Harris I brought in Erik
Weinstein I bring in people from the
left all the time we invite tons of
leftist guests who won't even come
because they don't want it to an
interview and I let them talk for like
15 minutes at a stretch because you want
to know what they think so then you can
critique what they think but the left
has decided that even having these
conversations is to grant credibility to
aside so evil that they must not be
heard and Whoopi Goldberg has a slot on
that show every single day everybody in
the audience knows what Whoopi Goldberg
thinks about these things wouldn't it
behoove Whoopi Goldberg and the folks on
the view to at least let Jeanine Pirro
make her point of view known especially
because you know the audience is gonna
laugh at Union Pierrot anyway because
it's a view audience it's just it
demonstrates real coward aside you know
props to Bill Maher props to Bill Maher
Bill Maher had me on a couple of weeks
ago
and perhaps Bill Maher who actually let
me talk we had a reasonable conversation
we disagreed about nearly everything his
audience was against me he acknowledged
that at the very beginning and then we
had a reasonable conversation good for
people like Bill Maher really because
there very few of these folks left in
American discourse and Whoopi Goldberg
and Joy Behar on the view demonstrated
pretty much every day it's really really
quite pathetic okay so let's get in
to the mailbag let's jump right in so
Neil says after her appearance on the
view judge she was apparently cursed out
and forced to leave the building by
Whoopi Goldberg does her experience on
the view deter you from wanting to
appear on it excellent first question
Neil the answer is no I want to go on it
more than ever because I think I can
have a good discussion with Whoopi if
she will allow us to have such a good
discussion especially because I think
that so many folks on the left wanna box
everybody on the right into the you're
an evil mangy terrible horrible human
being and people on the Left have
surprisingly hard time doing that with
people who are not terrible horrible
human beings I don't consider myself in
that category so I'm happy to have any
time a reasonable conversation about
these issues I think that's exactly the
reason why some folks on the view don't
want to have me on Jacqueline says my
husband and I are conservative parents
two five young boys under nine we are a
family with deep roots in the military
and police how can I help my boys
understand it's okay to be men real men
my sisters are very leftist lesbian who
hates men and voices it how do I keep
her around while keeping her from
negatively influencing my boys well
listen I'm not of the view then if your
family members are espousing viewpoints
that you think are bad for your kids you
have to have your family members around
your kids I'm not of that view now I
don't know your sister maybe she's a
very nice person maybe she's good for
the kids overall maybe you can talk to
her and say listen you espouse
viewpoints that I don't like in the
house about politics so we're just gonna
stay away from politics when we're
hanging out like I love you I want you
to be here but I can't have you
inculcating values and my kids that I
don't want my kids to learn maybe that's
a conversation you can have but I'm not
a person who believes that your
relationship with your sister Trump's
your relationship with your kids or your
capacity to teach your kids if you're if
it turns out that your sister is bad for
your kids keep your sister away from
your kids or kids are more important
than your sister
David s has been many of my friends
insists the cohabitation before marriage
is necessary for marriage to last I know
the data indicates otherwise but can you
explain exactly why it's a bad idea for
a couple to live together before
marriage are there any books that
explain the disadvantages of
cohabitation from a psychological
perspective thanks Dave so Jonathan Hite
talks a lot about this in the happiness
hypothesis there's a chapter on love and
he talked about why it is that
cohabitation before marriage tends to
lead to higher rates of divorce there
are a couple reasons in my view number
one is that the longer you cohabit the
longer you start to realize the real
reason your cohabiting and not getting
married it so you don't have skin in the
game so you're not locked down the real
reason that you're living together in
sin as they used to say the reason that
you are doing this is because both of
you want
a window ajar just in case you feel like
escaping without actually having to have
any legal entanglements that get in your
way that's what just reality that's one
of the reasons that you are doing that
because otherwise you would just go down
and get a piece of paper that says
you're married and be done you want to
leave that tour window ajar that's why
you're doing it and ladies if you think
that you're you're locking down a guy by
getting him to cohabit with you got bad
news for you you really really really
are not okay it don't mean a thing if it
ain't got that ring okay that's the way
this works yeah and and also I mean just
on the sociological level just on the
social science level I talked about this
a couple of weeks ago but there are two
types of love according to social
science there is what they call
passionate love and then there is
companionate love so passionate love is
what you have for the person that you
meet in the first six months really
first six months year of your meeting
and this is where you can't you want to
be the person every minute you want to
find out every single thing about them
you can't be apart from them youyou are
passionately in love with this person in
the sense that you want to be physically
intimate with them like every minute of
every day okay this happens a lot when
the person is new to you and then over
time you get used to the person and as
you get used to the person you begin to
love them in a different way which is a
companionate way you're grateful to that
person for the fact that that person
stays with you despite all your flaws
you know all of the little chinks in
their armor you know all of the good
things about that when all the bad
things about them makes you that much
more grateful to be in this battle with
them together that's a different kind of
love right you barely know the person
you marry typically you get to know that
person over the course of your life like
I didn't know compared to what I know
about my wife now I knew nearly nothing
about her when we got engaged
like really nearly nothing I just made a
bet and that bet was a good bet and I
think that the reason that bet is worth
taking when you're in the middle of that
passionate love stage as opposed to when
you're in the companionate stage which
is what happens if you cohabit for a
very long period of time is because if
you don't understand how marriage works
then what you tend to think is that
marriage is what turns passionate love
into companion love that it's marriage
itself that got rid of the passion and
this is what you hear from all these
guys who get it wrong I said oh you know
when I when choose my girlfriend man we
were at each other all the time and then
we got married and now we don't do any
of that stuff why did you get so boring
and the answer is no that's not what
happened it wasn't marriage that did
that what actually happened is what
happens in every relationship whether
you are married or not the reason you
should get married when you're
passionate because marriage should
continue to have that elements of
passion but you should move into
love when you are already committed to
the person because if you move into
companionate love when you are not
already committed to the person you're
gonna go searching for the passionate
love again with somebody else because
and inevitably whatever passionate love
you pursue will turn into companionate
love this is not me speaking and this is
social science speaking okay Brandon
says hey Ben I'm a little down this week
and in my thoughts haven't lost my
sister while I'm so sorry to hear that
happen Brandon really my heart breaks
for you it's that's awful I would like
to better understand the Jewish
perspective of grief and how to deal
with it properly thank you so choose
Jews have a very interesting way of
dealing with grief everything in Judaism
is somewhat ritualized so we have
something called sitting Shiva sitting
Shiva is where you basically as soon as
you hear that someone I'll give you the
whole spiel so when you hear that a
relative is dead a close relative like a
sister or brother or a parent or a child
then the first thing you do is you tear
your clothing is a sign of mourning and
you say bye Brooke died on high met
which is which means blessed is the true
judge meaning that God's justice is not
ours and he gets to make the decisions
about the world and then you go into a
period of mourning that period of
mourning is basically a period of
comfort it's a sitting Shiva Shiva means
seven for it for a week you sit in your
house and you don't go out of your house
like literally you don't go out of your
house and people come and they bring you
food and they pray with you they come
and they actually bring prayers to the
house like they'll bring a Torah to the
house that you can do Monday and
Thursday services at the house and they
will come and they will visit it's it's
one of the greater mitzvah but greater
mitzvahs that we have is to visit bait
show ava to visit somebody who's
mourning and you sit and you talk about
the person and you comfort the person
you talk about you know the the person
who's been lost and then for thirty days
after that for the ocean then you are
supposed to do I believe it's here
you're not supposed to listen to music
you're supposed to do certain things
that are that involve a little bit more
mourning but after the seven days you go
out of your house you leave your house
really you're not supposed to shower
actually for the seven days you're
supposed to go to like full mourning
you're supposed to you're supposed to
really kind of sit in it and experience
it so that by the time you finish those
seven days you're ready to get out in
the world again because you're so cooped
in and because you've been so kind of
ensconced in this in this basket of love
basically then now you're ready to go
out into the world again and then you
say Kaddish for a year so you say
Kaddish is this prayer that we say
repeatedly during the morning afternoon
evening services that basically suggests
that God is holy and knows what he's
doing and also it
is very based around the idea that there
are distinctions between life and death
good and evil etc so Judaism says that
you are supposed to you're supposed to
really be in the morning okay but now a
lot of people want to push off morning a
lot of people want to just I'll deal
with my morning by going out and working
more I'll go out and I'll deal with it
by ignoring it the problem is then it's
gonna hit you even harder I think the
Jewish way of mourning is one of the
more beautiful parts of my religion
actually so you can you can buy some
books on it there's a the Jew there's a
good book called the Jewish way in death
and mourning that I think is worth
reading
Jordan says hey Ben my older brother's a
classic American rags to riches story he
lives like a conservative and has
conservative values but is liberal
politically how's that even possible
the reason it's possible Jordan is
because most liberals live conservative
wife's if they're successful because the
rules that make you successful in life
tend toward conservatism like get
married get a job
save your money make good decisions with
your life these are all based on certain
conservative values the fact that your
your brother lives things liberal things
but acts non liberally is pretty common
there's a great book called coming apart
by charles murray all about the fact
that there are so many people on the
left particularly in white upscale areas
who live conservative lifestyles get
married have kids save their money make
good business decisions but then have
liberal views that end up being
promulgated on areas that don't live
those lifestyles and when those
lifestyles are actually tried they fail
and so people are very easily able to
ignore the way they live in their own
life in order to pursue political values
they think are important joel has been
since Roe view Wade's a bad case can
want to argue for digital privacy and
NSA restrictions Fourth Amendment
notwithstanding concern rose around the
SBI phone encryption backdoor dispute
blockchain implications that's pretty
complicated question there's a lot to
unpack but the the Fourth Amendment yeah
I don't know why you'd have to have a
generalized right to privacy in order to
make an argument against the NSA I mean
the Fourth Amendment is not is
withstanding the Fourth Amendment says
that there shall not be unreasonable
search and seizure
that's a Fourth Amendment consideration
okay that has nothing's with abortion
but it does have to do with the
government's ability to search and seize
your records as it always has had you
that's why there's a real balance that
has to be drawn between the needs of the
national security community and keeping
the country safe and protecting our data
I think that balance has largely been
drawn too much in favor of the NSA and
not enough in favor of individual
privacy
palce has been people including Clavin
and Jordan Peterson argue the big is
inherently bad even a friend
do you agree with this considering the
presence of natural monopolies with few
consequences no I don't agree with that
I think that big is not inherently bad I
think big is sometimes bad and small is
sometimes bad and bad is sometimes bad
that is always bad in fact so the idea
that a company is bad because it is big
no it was good to get big then the
question is do they deal with market
consequences and here's the truth unless
they are skewing the system unless they
are acting in corrupt fashion big is not
inherently bad I think big is in many
cases quite good I mean it's the reason
that you get economies of scale and
cheaper products for example Patricks
has been do you believe addiction is a
disease
do you believe any policy could be put
in place to help those who struggle with
disease and if so which ones it depends
how you define disease so I tend to
think addiction is not a disease in the
sense that it's not transmissible when I
think of disease I think of a
transmissible disease right I'm I guess
that you could say maybe cancer is a
disease although usually you would say
the cancer is more of like a medical
condition I guess I guess you could say
it's a disease is a disease in the sense
that it is naturally occurring sure I
think in that sense it absolutely is but
it is also a disease that can be fought
with with willpower which is different
than a lot of other diseases addiction
is something that that not always but
sometimes can be fought with competin is
why the 12-step program has been so
successful for alcoholics Anonymous I
mean that's it that's an active act of
self-control
so unlike other diseases that can't be
fought like you can't not have cancer
just because you determined that you are
not going to have cancer that's beyond
your control
addiction is partially beyond your
control and partially not and one of the
things about addiction is that one of
the ways you control addiction is
acknowledging that you have an addiction
and then creating prophylactic rules to
avoid getting into areas that put you in
a problem so if you're an alcoholic
you stay away from liquor stores if
you're if you are a drug addict you stay
away from parties where you know people
are going to be smoking pot for example
if you're a porn addict you put porn
blockers on your computer specifically
so that you're never tempted to click on
things
let's see Chelsea says in high school we
were taught that George Orwell was a
socialist yet so many conservatives
quote him what was his political stance
and what was his best essay Thanks well
George roll roll is fantastic he was I
think he would have considered himself a
socialist but he also understood the
problems with Marxism so it would be
more fair to call him sort of a
Democratic Socialist in the sense that
like the Europeans see it I'm not sure
that he believed the National is I like
a large-scale nationalization of
Industry I think you probably believed
more redistributionist program so he'd
be more more in line with sort of
Norwegian socialism for the Nordic
states in which as I've explained before
is sort of a mix of capitalism and
socialism but his best essay is the best
SAS er ever is something that's not even
about socialism or capitalism it's a
1940's a that he wrote specifically
about the appeal of Nazism it is just
spectacular accorded all the time
because his basic argument is that the
failure of the of both right and left in
modern society is to acknowledge that
people need meaning and so the reason
that the Nazis had succeeded in twisting
so many people's minds is because while
both right and left were focused on
capitalism makes us rich or Marxism
makes us more materially prosperous the
Nazis were focused on what gives people
spiritual meaning and they found an evil
way of giving people spiritual meaning
and people resonated to that his essay
basically says people do want flags
people want cannons people want guns
people want marches people want a
feeling of solidarity that's what people
are looking for it's something that I
think we've neglected in our society
that has become so materialistic I've
been writing an entire book about this I
talk about the book a lot it really is
good okay the book I just finished the
manuscript on it which I'm very very
excited about I may try to push up the
pub date with the publisher it's it's I
I don't want to be immodest here I think
it's the best thing I've ever written I
think it's really really good and I
think it'll help a lot of people and
quit help me clarify my own thoughts I
think it'll help a lot of people clarify
their own thoughts about Western
civilization what it means and how we
fight for it Stevens has hey Ben I've
heard you praise the sales-tax over an
income tax why do you consider that
better thanks and I love your show
I consider it better because I don't
think it's any of the government's damn
business what kind of money I earn like
why do I have to tell the government how
much money I earn I'm exactly the same
person that I was before
now the government you know and having
having capacity to examine transactions
seems to me a lot easier they can just
take the money at the cash register as
opposed to trying to go through how much
money I earn and then I take certain tax
deductions and then you punish me based
on how much money I earn it creates it
creates this this pathetic class warfare
system income tax we're a sales tax
really does not all right david says
well thomas has a quick one dear God
Emperor Shapiro pancakes or waffles I'm
a huge fan of the show well I appreciate
it
waffles is obviously answer waffles are
certainly I love I love both because who
doesn't love coke I mean Carver's are
amazing they're amazing they're God's
worst punishment on us carbs they're
unbelievable but while
are definitely better they have pockets
for butter and syrup okay they are just
made for deliciousness put some whipped
cream on top of that stuff some caramel
oh my goodness
is it a dessert is it a breakfast who
knows it's just unbelievable david says
this is a question I've held for a long
time since I respect your opinion I
agree with your assertions most of the
time and no you have a personal
understanding about the subject here's
my symbol here's my question can you
please explain the Star of David how or
when was it seen as the symbol of Israel
and most importantly where did it come
from its origins thanks for your apply
in advance my understanding is that the
first use of that was I believe during
the early part of the first millennia
first millennium I'd want to check this
out and get back to you honestly I don't
want to give you the wrong historical
answer on the history of the Star of
David but I know that you know it's been
part of Jewish prayers for for a long
time the MA NW or the ma gain they
sometimes they say my gain Alberta Homme
meaning the the star of Abraham alright
let's see we're uh let's do a quick
thing I like in the thing I hate because
we are we are past our expiration date
here and we're beginning to smell so the
things that I like there's a there's a
series on Netflix that I've started as a
Harlan Coben series I believe justified
was also a Harlan Coben series so this
is similarly good it's called safe and
it stars the guy from Dexter whose name
I completely forgot right now and sorry
Baal is it Michael and Michael seijo
okay okay Michael C Hall that's correct
and C is a middle initial okay and he
and the it is it is worth watching the
basic premise is that this guy's
daughter goes missing in a gated
community and everybody has secrets so
if you like these kind of juicy purple
potboilers and this is for you I check
out Harlan Coben safe on Netflix here's
some of the preview this is a gated
community
because he who comes in and who goes out
see you later not too late Jenny it's
dad again where are you
this man wants to know who sons daughter
okay so it's it's it's it's well made
I'm only about halfway into the series
but I'm enjoying it and then there are a
couple others if people have
recommendations on other series that
they think I should watch them then send
them to me because my wife and I are
always looking for the series to watch
I've heard that there's this one on
Netflix also that's about terrorism
that's supposed to be pretty good so
I'll check that out and all see if it's
worth the recommend okay time for a
quick thing that I hate so the media has
a grand interest in turning idiot
parents into a trend their latest trend
that they like is what they're calling
babies and of course not rabies babies
what are the babies okay this is that
you are raising your children without
gender which is idiocy because you're
supposed to teach your kids about things
that make them healthy not things that
make them unhealthy okay the fact is
that if you are confusing your
two-year-old about gender then you are
being an idiot like this is one this is
one I great question about this stuff
how do you think you're helping your kid
like really do you think it helps your
kid not to give them any guidance at all
would you let your kid not go to school
cuz your kid doesn't know anything about
reading and maybe your kid is better off
not reading maybe reading is a slat as a
societal construct and we know there are
lots of bad things that come from
reading like being on Twitter we know
there are terrible things that come from
education like a certain sense of non
equality with others you're an elitist
but now we've got parents who've decided
to raise their kids without a gender
designation which again how does this
help the kid at nobody the hell knows
so this is from Cambridge Massachusetts
because of course it is of course the
home of Harvard is the is the center of
stupidity in the universe
they say three-year-old twins xyler and
Kayden sharp scurried around the boys
and girls clothing racks of a narrow
consignment store filled with toys
xyler wearing rainbow leggings
scrutinized a pair of hot pink and
purple sneakers Kayden in the t-rex
shirt fixated on a must a musical cube
that flashed colorful lights at a glance
the only discernible difference between
these fraternal trends is their hair
sylars is brown and Hayden's is blonde
is either a boy or a girl
how about Kayden that's a question their
parents Nate and Julia Sharpe say only
the twins can decide or biology right or
we could
turn ative look at their genitals the
Cambridge Massachusetts couple
represents a small group of parents
raising babies children being brought up
without gender designation from birth a
Facebook community for these parents
currently claims about 220 members
across the United States how you think
that is good for your kid is beyond me I
have a four-year-old and a two-year-old
so I know a fair bit about raising kids
of precisely this age and listen I've
said on this program when my daughter
was two years old you know what she
really liked trucks and buses did I care
not at all because I don't think that it
is a natural indicator of masculinity or
femininity for a two-year-old to like
trucks or buses and you know what now
she's four and she only wants to wear
princess dresses it's the only thing she
wants to do you know why because that's
what girls typically want to do that
said my two-year-old son right he also
likes trucks and buses if he started
warning to our princess dresses you know
what I would say to him I would say no
that's a girl thing that's what your
sister does you know what you do you do
fun boy things like you play baseball
that's not a bad thing I'm not saying my
daughter can't play baseball I am saying
that my son cannot wear dresses because
I want my son to be secure in his own
masculinity and it turns out that being
a man means accepting some of the
societal constraints around manhood hey
now that doesn't mean when he's 18 or 20
he can't make his own decisions that's
when you're 18 or 21 he's 2 I get to
make those decisions and I want to
inculcate in my son a feeling that he is
a boy a strong boy who's gonna grow up
to have manly responsibilities for
taking care of women and children
manly responsibilities for defending a
civilization that makes important
distinctions between men and women I
think there is a good reason that the
Bible says that boys should not dress in
girls and girls should not dresses boys
because every society in human history
has made distinctions between how males
dress and females dress and don't give
me the Scottish wear kilts that's
correct
men were killed and women wear dresses
ok every society in history has had
distinctions and those distinctions are
deeply important because they inculcate
different responsibilities that are
indeed rooted in biology the idea that
all of gender is a construct is simply
not backed by science nor is it healthy
for society or even for individuals if
there are people who are confused then
we have to figure out how to deal with
that but to inculcate the confusion as a
point of politics is an evil thing to do
to a child ok well we will be here
tomorrow well no we won't you know it'll
it's give me a Saturday so we're not
gonna be here tomorrow why would I be
here tomorrow I can't even do that at
Sabbath ok we'll be back here on Monday
with much much more and the Sunday
special which is coming up on Sunday so
go check that out
Shapiro's this is the Ben Shapiro show
the Ben Shapiro show is produced by
Senya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy boring senior producer Jonathan
hey our supervising producer is Mathis
Glover and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Alex and Garo
Audio is mixed by Mike Carmina hair and
makeup is by Jess wah
of era the Ben Shapiro show is a daily
wire Ford publishing production
copyright Ford publishing 2018